what's your first few days writing a
webisode like uh I take so in terms of
short form this is just my process take
it however you want I mean there's
different ways to write it but like if
you're gonna write if I'm gonna write
like a four to five minute episode I
always say like if you can't and I think
this is pretty standard across the board
if you can't describe what's happening
your episode in one sentence then it's
too much is going on and you shouldn't
put it in you know under four minutes
like if there's an argument about a
check it should be like an argument
about a check takes place that's it
there's your episode or you know it's
kind of like the Seinfeld role to show
about nothing you know most good viral
videos and people that do them great
Funny or Die college humor all these
awesome sites even the YouTube vloggers
that do they're you know just
straightforward pov camera here's a
tutorial on how to do your eyelashes
like it's very just straightforward this
is what's happening in this few minutes
it's a very simple idea and this is why
those things go viral so that's kind of
my process to take that and then how do
you build around it you know how many
people do I need how many different sets
you know think of that in minds it's
just two people is gonna be one location
then the dialogue has to be pretty
entertaining for someone to sit there
because you usually have unknown actors
in the short-form stuff but if you have
a decent story and believable and good
actors which are there's a lot of us
sorry there I go got being a jerk and
thing and I'm good things there's a lot
of people out there that are good at
things and you get them in the right
spot people will watch it do's and
don'ts for webisodes cuz there's so many
people making them now that yeah I don't
I don't know like I don't you know I'm
not on a pedestal with everyone else I
just if I have an idea I just like to
make it and you know I've made duds and
I've made good ones and you know the one
that does well is the one you never
thought was gonna do well you know your
number one hit on your album is the one
you never thought people would like I
can't play music I don't know what am i
doing these music analogies I have no
musical talent but it's true is it what
hits on YouTube or whatever it is is is
sometimes an anonymous use me an anomaly
because we don't there's no rhyme or
reason sometimes what video there you
know
there's a million of them dudes getting
hit and then can I say it sure you know
no one's no too old teachers are always
there's the balls there's a million
videos out like that but one of them has
10 million views it's just it's just the
nature of the game you know cuz uh
someone with a huge clout and huge
following on social media decided that
was the one they liked that day and
that's the one they're gonna retweet and
it's just the nature of the beast
it's the influential people setting up
the cool kids at the lunch table well so
if since you don't want to come off like
you're on a pedestal and you're not my
no I'm just giving you're giving it it's
my opinion and it can't be worth as much
as you know I like that that's funny um
I see it came in my own two cents just
what does one pick what it's post I
think to do it I just think people just
need to do it cuz there's a lot of
people that write you know a bunch of
different stuff and it's awesome and I
think it's great and I'm jealous of
people to just sit down and write a
bunch of stuff but it's just I just like
if I have an idea just make it there's
gonna be someone out there that's not
doing anything one day that is willing
to come and help you and do it a shoot
and it's just gonna help in the long run
I've learned so much just from doing you
know learn to swim by jumping the deep
end
so for you for Anthony finale what are
your lists of what works and what
doesn't for your productions so we'll
keep it okay just bring your things and
you know going in I'm not gonna make
this webisode longer than 15 minutes
because I'm gonna lose my audience yeah
well that's the thing it's one of those
or if you have an audience and you have
established characters the more
establish you are the longer you can
draw stuff out so same thing with TV
shows you're seeing like the later years
you can tell there's a lot more improv
and the characters are having a lot more
fun than in like season one where it's
setup punchline setup punchline or
whatever it may be because they need to
get these characters established but
once people fall in love with it then
you can elaborate on it I think the same
thing can go for web video but you don't
really have time to establish characters
so you have to hit a point of view very
quickly on the TV side South Park is
just the best fit Amy Schumer is doing
him she's so great but like every sketch
that she does has a point of view like
like she'd that she did this one with
Bill Hader where she's like every girl
that gets interviewed on a late-night
talk show you know but that's her point
of view so everyone can come and me like
oh it's like taking something that she
would do in a stand-up set and making it
into a narrative same thing with Kim
peel they're doing the same thing like
taking something that you probably hear
one of them doing a stand-up set and
they put it into a narrative but it's
all that just that simple basic idea
like the annoying guy at the office or
the you know the guy that slaps ass in
the in the baseball locker room they
make a whole sketch about just that guy
and it's hilarious
and I think that's I mean don't
I'm not taught that's what I strive for
is one type of you know hit a point of
view how soon is conflict coming into
one webisode one short how soon is
conflict coming into like at the at the
zero marker - it's eight minutes I think
I think if you're fresh with it like it
just depends are you making like a
one-off video or is this part of like a
linear series then it's different but if
it's just a one-off video it's like you
might have a little bit of mush mush in
the beginning to get the ball rolling
with some jokes right but you need to
hit like what that one sentence
description is about within like the
first 30 seconds because people aren't
gonna I mean personally I wouldn't like
oh I don't know these people and I don't
know what they're talking about cuz I
don't I don't know them yet what is this
about I probably click next I mean even
all the great channels there still drop
off you know at the 50 75 percent mark
of the runtime screenshots what do you
normally put in for your screenshot that
you want I know that it's woman with
huge cleavage whether she's in there or
not I don't do that but that works
so obviously okay I think it has to be
relevant to the episode but if people
are putting their own thumbnails in
there and I think they should because
they determine that's the face that's
what people are seeing when it comes up
and whatever search they're doing that's
the first thing they're gonna see and
some of them default to the black screen
or the fade in or fade out so you've got
to be able to watch that and put
something good on there
you